so Sal here from Khan Academy and I'm
excited to be here with John Dickerson
co-host of CBS this morning and I'm
excited to be here too and some of y'all
might be wondering what are we doing
together and we are going to be talking
about civics and government and American
history and you're going to see a series
of videos on Khan Academy tapping into
Jon's
expertise you know when I cover the news
every single day one of the first things
I do is I go back and look at our
amazing American history for two reasons
one what is the standard been in the
past how people behaved in the past so
we know whether what's happening now is
new crazy interesting in keeping with
the American experience and the other
thing is when you learn about history
when you look to the past you can
sometimes have a clue about what's gonna
happen in the future even though things
are much different now with technology
and and the pace of things
turns out human beings behave the same
way in a lot of ways all throughout
American history so this is going to be
a very exciting as you could tell a
series of videos that some of them are
going to be John and myself and some of
them are gonna be John giving us kind of
connecting what you learned in school to
what's happening in the world around us